just some breaking news we're getting
involving the former prime minister
Boris Johnson and uh
it's reported that he's been referred to
police by the cabinet office over new
claims that he broke covid lockdown
rules this time apparently relating to
visitors at uh Checkers during the
pandemic let's speak to our political
correspondent Joe Pike so Joe the
problems mounting for the former prime
minister
indeed Mark especially as that
privileges committee investigation into
him potentially misleading Parliament uh
continues it's that committing
investigation which has effectively
prompted all of this the cabin office
officials at the heart of government
discovering in the prime minister's
ministerial diary evidence of visits uh
by friends of the former prime minister
to Checkers His official country
residence during the pandemic which it
would seem would be in contravention of
some of those lockdown restrictions now
the cabin office have referred these to
the police we understand both the Met
police and Thames Valley police I think
because Checkers is in the Thames Valley
police force area this is story broken
in the last few minutes by the Times
newspaper allies of Boris Johnson said
to think that this is politically
motivated they believe this is something
to try and damage the reputation of Mr
Johnson further he of course is in the
states at the moment speaking at an
event we understand in Vegas tomorrow a
statement I think from one of his
um one of Mr Johnson's AIDS in the last
few minutes some abbreviated entries in
Mr Johnson's official Diaries were
queried by the cabin office during
preparation for the covert inquiry
following an examination of the entries
Mr Johnson's lawyers wrote to the cabin
office and privileges committee
explaining that the events were lawful
and were not breaches of any covert
regulations so uh clearly Mr Johnson's
aides believing that these events were
lawful they did not break restrictions
and Boris Johnson's legal team
have made this clear they believe to the
cabin office and to the the Privileges
committed we understand at this stage Mr
Johnson has had no contact from the
police the two forces that met police
and Thames Valley police who have been
given this information by the cabinet
office Mr Johnson's team believed Eve
this is politically motivated and the
fact that he was given no notice before
the cabinet office made this referral
they think doesn't reflect positively
positively on the cabin office but
clearly Mark the whole issue around
partygate dogged Mr Johnson in his final
months it was one key reason why he left
government it is something that that
still is essential to understanding his
legacy and his future within politics
because he could have forced could of
course face a long suspension and
possibly there for a by-election in his
Uxbridge and South ruislip seat so we're
waiting to hear from both the Met police
and Thames Valley police see if any
action has taken any investigations
launched but clearly not a positive
development for the former prime
minister if it transpires that there
were more lockdown breaking events uh
not of course in number 10 of the cabin
office but at Checkers at his official
country residence I suppose it will come
down to How likely the police are to
revisit you know breaches or possible
breaches of breakdown rules during the
pandemic
exactly Mark and of course the Met
didn't move particularly quickly after a
party gate
um Revelations made the papers made the
newspapers and
broadcasters as well of course over 100
police fines were issued fixed penalty
notices were issued including to Miss
Johnson and of course to Rishi sunak as
well but it's not clear at this stage
that they have uh they have decided to
investigate certainly than that police
in terms of Valley police have received
this information they are deciding what
to do next but the very fact that the
cabinet office have discovered this
information in Boris Johnson's
ministerial diary that there had been
visits by friends to Checkers during the
pandemic is is itself very significant
um Mr Johnson's Aid clearly thinking
this politically motivated and that
angry at the cabinet office did not flag
what they were doing uh to him first uh
but a pretty I think significant story
for Mr Johnson and one broken by the
Times newspaper in the last 10 minutes
or so okay Joe thanks very much we'll
see what happens with all this uh Joe
thanks very much